todos los días sharifa Pasa varias horas
ayudando a su hermana pequeña con los
deberes oculta la herida de su oreja
izquierda Bajo su velo y calla su dolor
tarifa es una sobreviviente del ataque
suicida contra un centro educativo el
pasado 30 de septiembre
estas son mis amigas
Fátima está muerta
sabinar resultó herida y esta soy yo
cuando nos tomamos esta foto pensamos
que una vez terminados los exámenes de
acceso a la universidad no podríamos
vernos más tomamos esta foto como
recuerdo pero ahora ya no puedo mirar
estas fotos
me rompe el corazón sharifa y sus
compañeros estaban presentando un examen
cuando un terrorista suicida irrumpió en
su salón de clases el examen había
empezado había respondido a unas 10
preguntas cuando de repenteo y disparos
me escondí debajo de la mesa no recuerdo
lo que pasó después cuando volví en mí
todo estaba en llamas la pared del salón
de clases se había derrumbado y todo el
mundo corría de un lado a otro estos
videos aficionados publicados en las
redes sociales muestran la violencia de
la explosión todas las víctimas del
ataque eran de la etnia jasara La
minoría chiíta en Afganistán son mayoría
en Dash de barcie un barrio en el oeste
de kabul al día siguiente el atentado
decenas de mujeres afganas manifestaron
contra la violencia ejercida hacia La
minoría chiíta
una manifestación que fue dispersada por
los talibanes con disparos al aire
[Música]
Sacra es una de las manifestantes aquel
día estaba visitando la tumba de una de
las víctimas Marcia
soñaba con conocer París
marciar un Espíritu libre que soñaba con
poder caminar tranquilamente por las
calles de noche
caminar tranquilamente por la calle es
un deseo muy simple pero ninguno de sus
sueños pudo hacerse realidad sagria es
sobreviviente de un atentado suicida en
2018 se niega a guardar silencio tenemos
una responsabilidad Hace cuatro años
perdí a mis amigos en un ataque similar
y este año hemos perdido a estudiantes
como Marcia
tal vez Estas protestas no tengan
impacto tal vez no detengan el genocidio
de los azaharas Pero es mejor alzar la
voz en lugar de permanecer en silencio y
tolerarlo inaceptable
en el barrio jasara este Centro
Educativo tuvo que cerrar
tras el atentado del 30 de septiembre
los profesores del centro tienen miedo
había Dos clases aquí
cientos de estudiantes que pasaron por
Estos salones de clase han sido
aceptados en diferentes universidades de
Afganistán por problemas de seguridad
nos vemos obligados a cerrar esta
institución y destruir todas las aulas
hace 10 días este lugar se veía así
Esta es una foto tomada por uno de los
estudiantes que solía estudiar en este
salón de clases pero ahora todo está en
ruinas
el centro educativo tenía 800 alumnos
pero las nuevas autoridades talibanes
nunca pusieron en marcha ningún
dispositivo de seguridad A pesar de las
amenazas
la educación es la única y última
Esperanza para los hazaras porque somos
una minoría en Afganistán no tenemos
poder no tenemos armas no tenemos otros
recursos
la única salida es el conocimiento si la
situación continúa así retrocederemos
Cien años
la población chiquita discriminada en
Afganistán ha sido blanco frecuente de
los ataques del grupo terrorista estado
islámico desde 2015 uno de sus objetivos
son las furgonetas que sirven de
transporte público así se ha vuelto
especialmente cuidadoso
el año pasado un vehículo que estaba
justo delante de mí en la carretera
explotó
gracias a Dios no resulte heridos Tenía
mucho miedo los conductores de
furgonetas no tenemos mucho trabajo pero
tenemos cuidado de no recoger agentes
sospechosas
cuando estacionamos el vehículo no lo
dejamos solo
Siempre de un guardia vigilando
este pasajero también está tenso
y Estoy estresado tengo miedo de que
haya una explosión de que un terrorista
suicida se haga explotar en la zona de
darsevarchi se producen más atentados
que en ningún otro lugar Así que aquí
siempre tenemos miedo cuando uno sale no
sabe si va a volver a casa con vida o no
hoy en día parece que ser jazara fuera
un crimen los talibanes en el poder se
comprometieron a proteger a las minorías
hasta ahora han fracasado al igual que
el régimen afgano que los precedió